und wenn der rechtsstaat knallhart
durchgreift dann passiert das eigentlich
hinter verschlossenen türen und fernab
der presse anders aber bei einer razzia
in den frühen morgenstunden
dort war bild exklusiv dabei und im
fokus der ermittler steht ein
international tätiges pass feltscher
netzwerk der rechtsstaat kommt mit der
ramme seit heute morgen um 6 uhr stürmen
und durchsuchen einheiten der
bundespolizei in berlin und essen
mehrere wohnungen
sie wollen einer bande von passwörtern
und schleusern das handwerk legen
nach bild-informationen verhaften
spezialeinheiten in berlin den
drahtzieher
es handelt sich um einen gebürtigen
libanesen der 2013 nach deutschland
gekommen ist der vorwurf der mann hat
über einen fälscher ring in griechenland
gefälschte dokumente herstellen und nach
deutschland liefern lassen
hier versorgte er arabisch stämmige
personen die sich illegal in deutschland
aufhalten mit diesen dokumenten
außerdem verkaufte er pässe und visa
dokumente an migranten die noch im
ausland waren und mit hilfe der falschen
dokumente in die eu einreisen konnten
jetzt stimmt die polizei seine wohnung
und führt den mutmaßlichen kopf der
bande und bild reporter max kiewel ist
mir jetzt live zugeschaltet du warst als
einziger journalist dabei bei der razzia
wie ist denn genau abgelaufen
guten morgen es hat heute sehr früh
begonnen
gegen 4.30 haben wir die einsatzkräfte
getroffen und dann haben sie die sich
ausgerüstet die waffen geladen haben es
in dem film gerade gesehen und dann ging
es auch schon zum zielort ohne blaulicht
damit man hier am frühen morgen auch
nicht auffällt um die ecke geparkt ins
treppenhaus und dann mit der ramme rein
in die wohnung und was ist über den
täter bislang bekannt also wir haben es
gerade gehört khalil de heißt der
gebürtiger libanese 2013 nach
deutschland gekommen
und hat dann hier geschafft gemeinsam
mit passwörtern die in griechenland in
athen sitzen ein jahr internationales
netzwerk aufzubauen pässe dann zu
verkaufen an illegale migranten die in
deutschland leben und hier ihren status
legalisieren wollen oder aber auch
migranten die noch außerhalb der eu sind
dokumente kaufen wollen um damit dann in
die eu reisen zu können
und wie geht es jetzt weiter ja was wir
erfahren haben und das ist in diesen
tagen eine positive nachricht wenn wir
so oft über europäische zusammenarbeit
reden
zeitgleich zu der stimmung hier in
berlin sind wohl auch in athen in
griechenland wohnungen durchsucht worden
von eben genau diesen pass fälschern das
heißt gemeinsam mit europol sozusagen
wird jetzt europaweit ermittelt der
hauptverdächtige hier wird jetzt dem
haftrichter vorgeführt und vermutlich
dann die nächsten tage und wochen in
untersuchungshaft verbringen dankeschön
max kieffer freie information